I think this case is certainly the most
important case on the reach of federal
power in 50 years hi I'm Nicholas B with
reason TV and today we're talking with
the Pacific legal foundations Timothy
sandifer you're a principal attorney
there we're talking about Obamacare the
health care law that's being argued in
front of the Supreme Court let's break
it down on three big questions do you
think the Supreme Court will say hey you
know what we can't even talk about this
until you know Obama care goes into full
effect is no I think that's very
unlikely that that argument was adopted
by one federal court but it's really
hard to believe because it's definitely
going to go into effect and if something
is definitely going to go into effect
the courts can hear those cases what
about the individual mandate do you
think it will be found constitutional
and if it is does that really mean the
end of limited government as we know it
it it's hard to say and I it's dangerous
to predict what the Supreme Court is
going to do I would say I'm 5050 right
now on whether the courts going to
strike down the individual mandate which
is way better than when we started when
these cases started I thought there was
no chance of winning these cases but I
think that now that so many courts have
taken this issue seriously I think
there's a really good chance what has to
happen to tip it one way or the other I
mean is that the Stephen Breyer or
Justice Kennedy have to have like a
really bad lunch right before they're
listening to arguments what what will
govern how this I think it largely turns
on how Justice Scalia applies his Rach
concurrence if he if he says that what I
said in Raich only applies to
regulations of activity and this isn't a
regulation of activity then I he would
come down against the mandate on the
other hand if he says under my decision
in rage the government can regulate
anything that's necessary to make a
commerce regulation succeed then he
would have to uphold the mandate if the
mandate goes through it passes
constitutional muster does that mean
Congress would have the ability or the
government would have the ability to
make us eat broccoli to not eat broccoli
to chew broccoli a certain amount of
times before swallowing it
or is that all hyperbole I don't think
it's hyperbole I think that it would
then
be a political matter that's the real
difference here is whether there's a
constitutional restraint on what
Congress can do or whether it's all just
politics and if the court says that yes
the federal government can compel you to
buy health insurance then it would be a
matter of politics whether or not
Congress chooses to force you to buy a
Chevy Volt or buy whatever else they
think is good for society are good for
the economy or whatever a politician
thinks is a good idea what do you think
about the Medicaid expansion is that
going to go yes or no I think it's a
strong argument that the states have the
states are deprived of all Medicaid
funding if they don't comply the federal
government has never done something like
this before where it's expanded
eligibility requirements so dramatically
and although lower courts kind of have
all rejected this argument so far so far
I think that this case presents such an
extreme set of circumstances there was a
very famous case called South Dakota
versus Dole where the Supreme Court said
you know that's Elizabeth Dole right
Reagan's transportation circuit from
1987 on the South the state of South
Dakota was required to comply with
certain requirements in order to get a
certain percentage of its highway
funding the total amount of money at
issue in that case I believe is about
five million dollars and the court said
'no this the Congress can do that but
here we're talking I mean California
alone will lose twenty six billion
dollars if it doesn't comply and of
course would still be required to send
its taxes elsewhere more importantly
states are not allowed to opt out of
Medicaid as you know reason published an
article recently pointing out that under
the emergency treat medical treatment
act a federal statute also known as
EMTALA states are not allowed at this
point opt out of Medicaid and provide
alternative methods of taking care of
the poor a final question about
Obamacare issues if part of the law gets
struck down will that end the whole
thing or how will that plan that's
another issue on which the court will
hear an hour and a half of oral argument
on Wednesday I think that the court will
strike down the whole thing all at once
or not at all I don't think they're
going to get going to want to get into
the business of basically redesigning
the statute in a way that Congress never
intended sometimes they do that and they
could do that here there's no reason
that Congress couldn't that the court
couldn't just strike out the mandate
and leave the rest in place but to do so
would basically be rewriting the statute
and I don't think the courts gonna want
to do how on a scale of you know Dred
Scott versus Plessy versus Ferguson
Korematsu you know how important is this
as a Supreme Court case well it
certainly doesn't rate like Dred Scott
contrary to Professor Akhil amar
claiming that striking down the mandate
and upholding constitutional principle
was like Dred Scott but I think this
case is certainly the most important
case on the reach of federal power in 50
years and I think it's really amazing
that the court has granted three days of
oral arguments something it has not done
in at least a century I mean we're
talking about the days of Daniel Webster
here so I think the court is taking it
extremely seriously because although in
this case you're talking about just one
law that in the scheme of things doesn't
seem all that important the
constitutional principle of where does
the line where is the line drawn on
federal power that is a matter that our
children and grandchildren love to do
and let's also point out that they are
the Supreme Court justices are
government workers so when we say three
days what we're talking about is really
what a like a total of about six hours
that's right yeah okay spread out over
three days I'm the one that has to stand
in line for six hours now Pacific Legal
Foundation the nonprofit law firm that
you work for recently had a Supreme
Court victory in sac and V EPA quickly
what is the what's the import of that
decision that case involved the EPA's
use of what are called compliance orders
which are government orders issued by a
single bureaucrat on the basis of quote
any information whatsoever end quote
that declare you are out of compliance
of the Clean Water Act and force you to
come back into compliance by planting
all sorts of trees or roping off your
property all that sort of thing for
three years and if you don't comply you
get fined seventy five thousand dollars
per day is the total possible fines and
you're not allowed to sue the government
to challenge their jurisdiction what the
Supreme Court said in this case is that
under the under the Administrative
Procedure Act you do have the right to
sue and challenge the EPA's jurisdiction
so thanks to PLF the Sacketts now get to
go back to court and hopefully beat the
epa on the merits of the compliance
that's right and we're pretty optimistic
about that because
not only is their property perfectly dry
land but it's a normal everyday
subdivision there are built up
properties all around it and the federal
government clearly abused its power in
this case as it has done in so many
other cases where people didn't have the
wherewithal to defend themselves in
court
great well Timothy sandifer principal
attorney at the Pacific Legal Foundation
I want to thank you for talking to us
about Obamacare and the Supreme Court
for Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie